there was a guy who was on this podcast
you know John Bernthal he was talking
about this guy that he interviewed he
was going to blow up a mosque
assalamualaikum greens at peace
now recently some of you shared with me
some clips with our old friend Joe Rogan
whoa some of the most disciplined people
that I know are very religious it's
really fascinating particularly Fighters
where he's praising the Muslim lifestyle
like a lot of the Islamic Fighters out
of Dagestan they're some of the most
dominant Fighters and some of the most
religious Fighters so devout and because
they don't have the distractions that a
lot of the hedonists do he talks about
them not partying drinking and all the
other debauchery that goes into that
dark black hole of following your lusts
and desires and because they don't have
the distractions that a lot of the
hedonists do yeah you know they're not
party like the guys out of khabib nurmag
madoff's camp or some of the most
dominant Fighters they're they wear
their hair all exactly the same way and
these are men it's not that like they
don't like women but they just have
wives and they can have up to four and
practice something all they care about
is like family religion training they
they don't chase girls they don't drink
they're just they're they're just
training constantly so they're not out
there come in adultery fornication porn
screwing around and they practice all
they care about is like family religion
training they they don't chase girls
they don't drink drink they're just
they're they're just training constantly
like insanely dedicated to their craft
and they're the most dominant they are
committed to their family respect of the
parents love proper bringing to the
children so they can be good human
beings and their religion is the way of
Jesus if you didn't know it's that pure
monotheism stick with this for a second
the way of life of Moses of Abraham of
Jesus in the last final messenger the
problem peace and blessing be upon them
of the worship of the one and only
creator of the heavens on Earth but not
his creation and being morally upright
he Praises this lifestyle the lifestyle
of being humble like Habib he talks
about he has millions but he's driving a
Toyota truck khabib is very wealthy yeah
and he drives a Toyota truck I mean he's
uh he lives in the same house I mean
it's like he's very devout in his
beliefs and if I understood him
correctly he's talking about Habib how
he totally left the game alhamdulillah
and now he just got out I think he's
decided to retire completely from mixed
martial arts coaching and everything
very religious now that's not what I
want to focus on I want to bring your
attention to what he you guys brought my
attention to with these clips where you
shared an interview that he did with a
John birth knaul this famous actor where
they talk about a American Military
Marine I've had him on a program his
name is Richard McKinney let's look at
this clip where John berthal is
narrating the story
to Joe Rogan now please excuse the
musical instruments I just want you guys
to see this video so we can comment on
it Richard McKinney used Murray any
Force Recon and he was overseas during 9
11. I believe he got injured and then he
came home he's from Muncie Indiana he
just had this like unbelievable hatred
of Muslims at the same time the Muslim
Community in Muncie was growing there's
this wonderful woman who created
something called the Muncie Islamic
Center she brought in over 157 Muslim
refugees into America he was seeing more
and more Muslims in the community it was
driving him crazy he's gonna go blow up
this Islamic Center he built a bomb
walked into the center when he walked in
there he was met by that woman BB she
greeted him in this way that he had
never seen before she invited him she
gave him a crime he really wanted to
read it he thought that he was going to
find proof in this Quran that all these
people just wanted you know Americans
dead so he decided to leave that day and
come back still with this plan to blow
up the Islamic Center on a Friday there
would be 200 people there and the woman
invited him into her home and and cooked
for him now years later he's a devout
Muslim he's the president
whoa they are like family and I had both
of them on the on the podcast a very
amazing story isn't it and then Joe
Rogan goes on to narrate this same story
to one of his other guests take a look
there was a guy who was on this podcast
you know John Bernthal he was talking
about this guy that he interviewed he
was going to blow up a mosque he had
this hate of Muslims after coming back
from overseas from serving and he was
going to blow up moss and he went in
there and he met this woman who welcomed
him into the mosque and he was still
totally intent on blowing her up blowing
everybody up she invited him over her
home for dinner he was still intent on
it so he gets to know her and his family
completely change his course becomes a
devout Muslim wow and then talked about
the whole experience so we commend you
Joe I think Joe's come a long way step
by step I think in the past he's had
some guests who have affected him in a
negative way some pseudo-intellectuals
who really knew nothing properly about
Islam were not properly properly
educated and we've had to call these
things out out we've had people such as
Muhammad hijab and Maham Mustafa and
others to come on and to look at some of
these things that have been said you can
watch some of those programs in the past
so just we keep it fair in Balance so
the things that he's done in the past we
call that out now we want to be fair and
balanced he's speaking highly praising
the Muslim lifestyle which is connected
to Islam so we want to commend him for
that keep moving forward and God will
inshallah he can have just like one of
his best friends Lex Freedom he had a
Imam on his program and he can go and
bring someone on and go more in depth
with some of these stereotypes that
people have regarding Islam now for
those of you who want to hear more about
this amazing story that Joe Rogan was
talking about and John birth now who I
I'd like to have if you guys can go
ahead and get this message to him I'd
like to have the invitation still open
to Joe Rogan to have him on the program
we'd love to have you on and John
birthnau love to have you on to talk
about this interview that you did with
our brother Richard McKinney and for
those who want to hear more of the story
and four I'm Gonna Leave You with a clip
with this amazing story of our brother
American Military Marine Richard
McKinney
and that's the program I did it's the
dean show 746 just go on my channel
there subscribe hit the notification
Bell and look for the show number 746
and you can see the full interview that
I did with Richard McKinney this story
that Joe Rogan famous actor John birth
now we're talking about thank you very
much guys we'll see you next time here
in the dean show until then peace be
with you
and they said why do you want to go back
to Iraq
I said I'm not done killing Muslims two
tours in Somalia Bosnia uh Afghanistan
and Iraq yeah you know I wouldn't have
been called a terrorist which is what I
would have been yeah because I'm white
because I don't have religious
affiliation as far as Islam now if I
would have been a Muslim and did
something like that to a supermarket we
know how that goes yeah that story is
easily predictable oh yeah so so but she
goes what do you mean I said they're all
Muslim
like it didn't matter they're the other
yeah they're the other because she knows
I hate Muslims yeah I'm reading the
Quran what is going on man right
the famous saying that's usually always
said by a bigot is that I don't want my
family around those people yeah I would
be considered a criminal I knew that
but I saw it as doing one last thing for
my country
and I knew I would end up in federal
prison I knew I would end up with a
needle in my arm I knew that and that's
the way I felt if I got rid of this
hatred I would die because it's the only
thing keeping me alive
and I was like bam
I want to see what they got to say about
this so they explained it and it was a
an historical passage I decided without
telling anybody I'm gonna go visit these
people I'm gonna give them a chance to
prove me wrong I mean I was raised with
uh Christian values I guess you'd say my
my my mom was fairly religious in in
Christianity so you would have been at
that point in my life at least America
was my religion eight weeks later
from the first day I stepped foot in
that in that Islamic Center I took my
shahada I cannot leave without giving
you a gift if you are not yet Muslim and
you're tuning in to see what these
Muslims are talking about and you like a
free copy of the Quran go and visit
thedineshow.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum
[Music]
we're here
yeah all right guys so we signed
everything here
[Music]
yeah
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
please
[Music]
around here it's it's pretty huge and uh
like this the place the location that
you opened and basically it's far
further south from the other other big
massages and everyone I know a lot of
people but I used to I come my cousin
lives nine minutes from here another
Uncle of mine lives about five to ten
minutes from here this area
opened up in an area that it's much
needed and this size yeah I mean this
the center this Center is much needed
for this area and the idea of this
Center is for the whole stick because we
don't have anything like that in the
whole state that was censor where it's
gonna basically nurture and basically
educate and it's gonna basically spread
Islam